قذيفه يصل مداها الى 250 كيلو متر تدرس
واشنطن ارسالها الى كياب لاستمرار في
ترجيح كفتها في ظل الحرب الجاريه بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا البنتاجون تلقى اقتراحا
من شركه بوينج لتزويد اوكرانيا بقنابل
دقيقه صغيره الحجم ورخيصه التكلفه يتم
تثبيتها على صواريخ متوفره بكثره المنظومه
التي اقترحتها بوينغ يطلق عليها اسم قنبله
ذات قطر صغير تطلق من الارض اي من فوهات
مدفعيه مثبته على الارض وتصيب اهداف على
بعد 150 كلم
وتجمع وتجمع المنظومه بين قنبله جيبي يو
همم 39 ذات القطر الصغير ومحرك صواريخ ام
تونسي سكس وكلاهما متوفر في مخزونات
الولايات المتحده العسكريه بكثره طريقه
امداد اكياس بالزخيف همم ذخيره ستكون
اليساسيه مع امتلاك الاخيره عددا لا باس
به من المدافع الغربيه خصوصا من طراز
هيمارس ووصول هذه الذخائر سيتيح لاوكرانيا
ضرب اهداف عسكريه روسيه حيويه كان من
الصعب الوصول اليها فضلا عن مساعدتها في
مواصله هجماتها المضاده وعن الوقت المتوقع
لتسليم هذه الذخائر الى الجيش الاكراني
كشفت رويترز الا انه يمكن ان يبدا في وقت
المبكر من ربيعه عام 2023 ما يعني بعد
اشهر القليله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]